In Avengers: Endgame, the dusted heroes arrive
just in time to assist the surviving Avengers
in taking down Thanos.
Just as Captain America thought he'd have
to go it alone, portals begin opening across
the sky.
The very first hero to step through is Black
Panther, and we finally know why.
Avengers: Endgame co-director Joe Russo recently
revealed during a Reddit Ask Me Anything session
that the King of Wakanda wasn't technically
the top choice to return first, Sam Wilson,
a.k.a. Falcon, was.
Joe and his filmmaking brother Anthony Russo
wanted Sam to be the first person to communicate
with Captain America during the battle with
Thanos.
"Cap, it's Sam.
Can you hear me?
On your left."
Since Sam was fighting in Wakanda when he
disintegrated in Avengers: Infinity War, the
directors knew that they needed to have the
Wakandan portal be the first one to open up
after Professor Hulk's Snap.
Given that Sam isn't the most important person
in Wakanda, T'Challa wound up being the first
hero to emerge.
In Endgame, Sam is the hero who is heard first,
telling Cap through his communications device
that the heroes are arriving to his left,
but Black Panther is the first one seen.
Russo added that:
"We spent a lot of time in the edit room playing
around with the sequencing of the portals.
We probably didn't lock that section of the
movie until about a month before the film
was in theaters.
We always wanted Sam to be the first one to
communicate with Cap via his comm and Sam
was last in Wakanda, so logically the first
portal that would open would be the Wakandan
portal...the first person that would logically
walk through a portal from Wakanda would be
the king himself, bringing his army once again
to the defense of Cap and the world."
Joe added on the audio commentary track included
on the digital release of Avengers: Endgame:
"Who else would you want to have your back
in this moment other than T'Challa and Wakanda?"
Sam letting Cap know that he's got someone
coming in on his left is also a reference
to a fan-favorite moment in Captain America:
The Winter Soldier, in which the Star-Spangled
Avenger keeps lapping Sam on their run.
"Don't you say it, don't you say it."
"On your left."
"Come on!"
In the end, Black Panther being chosen as
the first hero to return after Professor Hulk's
Snap wasn't down to some big, emotional reason.
It wasn't even due to T'Challa and Wakanda
being some of the Avengers' most loyal allies.
The real explanation has a lot more to do
with logistics.
They wanted Sam to communicate with Cap first,
Sam was in Wakanda when he was snapped away
into the ether, and Black Panther is the king
of the nation, so he showed up first.
Easy breezy.
The issue of which hero would return first
after the Snap in Avengers: Endgame wasn't
the only logistical issue the film's team
had to tackle.
Endgame co-writer Stephen McFeely revealed
on the Endgame commentary track that he and
his writing partner Christopher Markus wrote
a version of the script in which the heroes
came back and were shown immediately:
"Just on an act-construction level, we were
faced with a strange problem where we needed
two snaps of the Gauntlet and asked ourselves
often, 'What does it mean to bring everybody
back?'...We certainly tried a version where
everyone came back and you knew it immediately,
and there they were...Doing that prevented
us from a really heroic reveal."
And what a heroic reveal it wound up being.
Black Panther entering alongside Shuri and
Okoye, then giving Captain America a knowing
nod as Sam flies overhead?
We're getting chills just thinking about it.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.